and so at this point i'll just go back
to Gen again on Long Island and I'm
going to put the picture of her unit
back up because we didn't have much time
to talk about that um and so Jan I have
one question for you in looking at this
zone building unit does this unit
actually do any deep tillage it has a
shank on it it's not deep by any means i
would say you think eight inches which
six about six inches that goes down it's
a very small shank can you tell us what
is the make of this that's a yeter the
whole business is a header yes and do
you know anyone else who's using this or
does anyone here do we know of any other
growers that are using yeter if you were
going to try Jen you've only do one row
at a time but is there anything that you
would like to change about this unit to
improve it for your situation I think
one of my biggest questions is is how
much residue is too much or too little
we have quite a bit because we always
think the more the better but I'm
wanting to hear from other growers what
they have experienced is whether we
really need all that residue and then it
would I think that zone biller builder
would work it's worked very well for us
the wind had it set up but with less
residue would work even better and again
your goal is having a lot of residue
because you have pumpkins there yeah it
keeps the pumpkins clean and from what
we feel it's supposed to help with the
weed control but we're happy weed
control so then you then go on to
putting on strategy and sandhya but then
you have to get it incorporated into the
spill and with more residue you need
more rain to get it down into this
if it does make it into the soil so um
for other four I know Georgia pumpkins
with a lot of rye residue and does yours
look like um hers in the spring she
wants to know if her if your look like
hers does with that much oh my my I
don't have that much residue that looks
like a little bit more and i'd like to
have I had one year like that the air I
told you I had to roll it and the
problem was that it held the moisture so
bad that it was just awfully awfully wet
underneath that big matter residue way
more than I wanted and the soil was a
lot colder there and I had a slug
problem so I don't have only about half
that much residue when I I sprayed the
dry and let it fall down when it's about
24 30 inches high and I don't let it get
as heavy as that is but and I for that
reason because this it does to holes too
much moisture I experience oops I'm
sorry go ahead do you have trouble with
we control with the less residue how is
the wheat management with that I have
had no really good luck I talked to
Robin blender some years ago and I she's
got me doing the strategy sandhya and
when i plant and then i go in 30 days
later with the other I put a half ready
to sandia on and go in 30 days later
with the other half and select to get
the grass if there is any and for the
last few years I've had very very
excellent weed control with about half
as much residues in that picture there
if the goal is to build up organic
matter from a larger amount of organic
mass when do you stop worrying about it
I it seems to me that most of this
conversation this morning has been
towards less residue rather than more
but if a goal is to build up the organic
matter from a health standpoint how do
we address that cover crops yep unless
tillage you want less tillage and look
the idea the less residue is
make your planner work better but you
want to do cut the tillage out which is
what burns up the residue in the first
or the organic matter in the first place
and then make it up with cover crops who
ain't after as soon as you get a crop
off the fields go in and plant some kind
of a cover crop right behind it and
build your organic matter with your
cover crops but the building organic
matter really centers around very very
few tillage trips I'm a firm believer
that one ripping or stripping pass and
one planting pass is all the tillage
that we should be talking about in most
cases and once our soil recovers and
gets to be structurally better then we
can get by with a quote no-till with
some zone till Coulter's on the planter
so you can in fact have a one-pass plant
existing but you can't get by with one
pass planning until you get your soil
softened up and the structure better and
the organic matter brought up a little
bit takes from Ventus about a organic
matter to raise the organic matter in
the soil test you know as found in the
field the tillage just burns that up
like a brush pile on fire we've had
we've done some studies where we look
that we're applying lots of organic
matter onto the field over time and the
amount that is needed to actually move
this test the organic matter test is
tremendous but what we do observe is
after a couple of years even with just
using a rye cover that we detect
differences in aggregate stability in
the soil very quickly so you can have
the affecting soil health and so
equality when you're incorporating all
these practices together despite not
seeing that organic matter number change
and the part of that to remember is that
these different types of cover crops and
and and the types of organic matter
carbon that you're adding to this
they're broken down at different rates
by soil organisms to create that
aggregate stability and to actually help
improve soil filter the soil but those
but those benefits are accruing prior to
actually seeing big changes in the
number
because we have different fractions
different size of particles in different
ways in which organisms attack this
organic matter so I think that just as
Jim and George have been saying it's the
combination of activities that we have
between adding organic matter reviewing
our tillage looking at the rotation and
the combinations of crops in the way
that we're doing all of our management
across a whole rotation are important
factors affecting how that organic
matter is going to change so your your
machine with you had standing ride a
lower density could you run it and you
killed it with Roundup could you run it
through that through your machine if the
word that I think it'll work than
anything I still am questioning if at
masa we have there is gone in a one year
rotation is that not benefiting the land
and as far as tillage goes that's strip
and then the planner through it is all
the toe is that ground will see this
year in one year and there's been no
mobile cloud no disking positions it's
all been vertical tillage and with seen
an increase in the organic rate small
but albeit an increase but if that
material is is disappearing is that good
or not well it definitely being
incorporated and broken down in the soil
so I don't see that it could be bad it's
definitely working to build yourself
quality then why shouldn't we make the
machinery work for that to that goal and
are you are you saying that you don't
believe that it's working that way right
now because I'm looking at this picture
and it looks like it's doing a nice job
no I i think it is doing a nice job and
we're looking to add even more okay just
pointed passing your observation I guess
if the picture of the allis-chalmers
deep till her the cornell unit that a
newest guy i put that together and i
ended up with the three Coulter's way
out front in the number of times that
thing has been used and we've had a
better mini Mountain built that's
chopped up finer so we got the three
cultures way out front those are good
jobs then we got in the deep toe shank
then we got the role clean closing a row
cleaner deal and then the closing
cleaner closing halters and rolling
baskets and I wonder if that thing would
work better down there to make a nice
Brown even textured band for the planter
to work into or transplant or whichever
we use it
nothing shoot you did no no no I was
trying to bring it up oh you're trying
to bring it up there are attempts you'll
notice folks that there's three
Coulter's way out front on that thing
and that's just going away the iron let
me put some of that stuff together so
there's three quarters out front kind of
preparing a band for the deep teller you
know and then with her closing Coulter's
enrolling basket we've had pretty good
luck and some of these situations with
that working and I wonder if in the ride
you know in Jen's case you know we need
three quarters out front I don't know as
opposed to the row cleaner is trying to
get cleared out way out front as we do
have a tremendous man of stuff there I I
think that it is one of those situations
where it's not all changes in the setup
of the unit can have a big impact as the
quality of the zone that's a we've
observed changing the angles of the
closing Coulter's all of the just a
minute and playing with it in a
situation to be able to have the time to
do that's been really critical
especially in start-up so in thinking
about getting into doing this I think
it's particularly important is to start
slow and and to encourage if you're
interested in sort of doing a
demonstration to consider having a unit
that you can actually try on different
fields and then manipulate and and and
and change some of the way that this
unit is set up so you can learn how it
is performing in your system so because
in each particular scenario it might be
slightly different I know well you're
while you're on that I'd like to add a
comment about a comment that was made
earlier about when when you should plant
after zone tilling and I think George at
the time said you should let it settle
for a while after after you zone till
and that's not the experience that
growers in New England are having most
of them
our zone tilling and planting the same
day or the very next day Tom Scott sit
next to me he's hooked up his planter to
his zone tiller so he's doing both in
one pass we have nope haven't had any
problems which stands said it doesn't
doesn't seem to need to settle I know if
you take a penta trauma Teran feel down
through that slot it feels like about 10
inches down that there is a spot avoid
about 4 inches we were concerned about
that at first but we haven't seen any
problems with seed settling or the soil
settling and causing problems with the
stand so for anybody that wants to try
it that way it could be the difference
between New York soils and New England
soils most of the vegetable growers in
New Englander on sandy loam soils and
which is not having a project yeah Joey
I'm comment on that I agree with you to
a disc extent i was talking about
heavier soil in my clay soil I have done
zone telling in the clay soil and gone
back three four weeks later and I can
still poked a penetrata right down to
slot that Defra it hasn't sealed up if I
do it to spring on my sandy soil which I
have blow sand in them one field that I
have sweet corn in I don't don't tell
anymore I just leave it alone just plant
right in it i mean i don't use his own
builder but in the loamy soil or the
lighter soils i agree with you that you
don't have to wait very long but the
bulk of my soils are heavier and
particularly the heavy clay and i like i
said i can go back there a month later
and it still got an open slot down under
if I'm not careful well that's kind of
what I meant great alright folks up what
kind of at the end of the time that we
had for this video conference I really
hope that dumb stunned me oh you did you
guys meet out there and we're in New
York I can hear all your giggles I said
it's time to eat last time anyways I
want to thank you all for joining us and
again remember that um you know have
lunch but take this opportunity to visit
with folks it
in your site to talk some more about
doing zone tillage and if you're in New
York again we have some funding to help
underwrite caught on the sort of setting
up of demonstrations we're happy to do
that happy to work with you to
coordinate that and again if you have by
chop there on your farm we are looking
for other collaborators and we will be
at your farm if you are collaborating
doing numerous tests on your own behalf
of the project but hopefully things that
you can use to learn from as well